Special Counsel Robert Muller removed
one of his lead investigators over
potential bias the agent was reassigned
last summer after it was discovered he
sent text messages that may have
criticized the president Paula Reid is
outside the district court house in
Washington with more Paula good morning
good morning this agent was a top FBI
investigator working alongside Special
Counsel Robert Muller Peter sterzick was
reassigned after sending politically
charged text messages to another member
of Muller's team FBI lawyer Lisa Paige
sterzick was also a key player in the
investigation into Hillary Clinton's use
of a private email server but he's now
been reassigned to FBI's HR department
now this was such a significant
development the special counsels office
actually issued a statement saying
immediately upon learning of the
allegations it removed Peter sterzick
from the investigation now Republicans
are using this reassignment to question
the credibility of both the Clinton
email probe and the ongoing Muller
investigations President Trump tweeted
over the weekend now it all starts to
make sense
Attorney General Jeff Sessions who has
recused himself from the Russia
investigation has also weighed in he
says that he wants to ensure that all
federal investigations are conducted
without bias or favoritism and that he
has addressed this with the FBI director
all right Paula thank you so much